hey guys welcome back to bone shaker
this video isn't really centered on
anything in particular just in general
finishing much of the scenery around the
roller coaster so it's just a lot of
really small things here and there that
I'm working on though a couple of main
things include this new flap right
around here there were also be a crane
which actually surprisingly happy with
how it came out in the end and some
general path work and working on the cue
of the coaster to basically finish most
of the scenery in one episode for the
entire coaster which is something that I
didn't really expect and it all went by
pretty quickly but there is still of
stuff to do as well which you'll
probably see at the end of this video
where I still have a real-time pilot as
well anyway I just wanted to get some
simple scenery around here make this
almost a little dark ride point there
aren't really any dark ride parts in the
coaster but I just wanted to make sure
that especially these less visible parts
do have some scenery to keep it
interesting and not just leave the caves
completely empty and now this bench
thing is something that I don't think I
can really take credit for I am pretty
sure that it has to be done before I
decided to do it basically somebody on
reddit I called David
Devilfish that's it we're actually
posted it on YouTube is well posted a
tutorial on how to make picnic tables
out of the driftwood which is an
absolutely amazing item because it's
really small and it has a perfect blank
sort of texture and shape to it so you
can really make a lot of stuff out of it
it just usually takes a lot of time and
effort to do so but he actually made
picnic tables out of them and uploaded a
tutorial on YouTube how to make them
which I'll share in the description if I
don't forget to do so but I haven't
really seen anybody make just regular
benches out of them and I just really
wanted to get some path elements in here
there's no real way to get some good
looking little bins yet I think so I
probably won't mess with those yet but
it's just a good way to get some extra
path elements on the paths just to make
those look a bit more interesting and
just for realism sake it's always really
cool to just add some benches around
areas where the coaster passes by or you
have a great view to just have one of
those places where you can just sit down
and have a look at the coaster
especially because this is no such a
family car
and family-oriented park that it is in
supposedly and around the queue I just
wanted to have some simple scenery I'm
not going to do too much with this area
and how I'm not entirely sure what I'm
going to do with this area but I just
wanted to have some simple rock work and
foliage around here just to of course
make this look a bit interesting but I'm
not gonna really tie it in too much with
the steampunk scenery of the rest of the
ride which is sort of in the same vein
as the sort of detail argument that I
had in the last video which is that I
don't have too much detail in the entire
ride to make everything look too
confusing and I do and I have like focus
the detail on certain areas and keep
some other areas just some plains of
grass and books and keep them more empty
and I just wanted to have that sort of
middle part which is a little bit less
heavily themed hands also why I was able
to do quite a bit more in this video
than in the last two videos at least
that's how it kind of looks anyway well
I didn't want to have is I was still
looking for a use for those gears
because I figured well I've made those
skills and they took quite a bit of time
to make and I kind of like the girls
anyway so I wanted to do something with
them but I did want to have something
using which I could actually have a
functional use for the gears to not make
them look too out of place and I figured
what would be quite nice both for the
gears and just as a general thing to
have would be a crane like this which
isn't really the easiest thing and I
have to be very honest this was not the
first crane I built I built a couple and
they all filled miserably and I'm glad I
don't even have footage of it anymore
but this one is actually one I am quite
happy with I did want to like spend
quite some time to get it in this sort
of sense that I wanted to because even
though it's a really simple crane I
didn't want to go and make things too
complicated for a reason which I'll talk
about in a second it's still took quite
some time to get it right basically I
wanted to get something which doesn't
just look like a crane or doesn't just
look like it resembles a crane but
something which just is a crane which
just looks like it
well it's a real functional crane just
because I rather not have something
instead of trying to get something in
there just to have it and have it look
really unrealistic just because I think
that just completely take you out of the
immersion part of the theme-park is to
get that sort of suspense of disbelief
to some degree and make it realistic
beyond that and that's also kind of why
I would rather if I'm not able to make
something into something that looks
convincingly like what it's supposed to
look like I think it's just better to
leave it out anyway because it just
doesn't really add anything to the
experience but it just takes away from
it if it looks well completely
unrealistic and there are still a couple
of gripes which I have with this crane
as well one of them is the fact that
after trying to well see how I could
make the cable itself I ended up just
using the little roof thing which you
can pretty much tell as a roof it only
kind of Falls you from like quite a
distance I feel I'm also not a crane
master so maybe I did mess up on a
couple of things on this crane even
though it's a really simple crane but I
just figured it would be nice to have a
crane around here it's just to have an
extra scenery elements over here because
I figured if I wouldn't have anything
than the transition from the towers on
the top and the quite heavy theming over
there to the more empty and less heavily
themed areas down here would be very
rough and awkward and it's also just a
really good way to use those gears which
I still wanted to use for something and
I'm quite happy with how it turned out
in the end I might tweak it a little bit
just like everything and I'm always open
for feedback as well but this is sort of
like the general look of the crane and
cranes are also just one of those things
which you see a lot in steampunk themed
things so it's just something I really
wanted to get in there I'm not sure if
I'm really gonna want to make any
additional cranes though because it
absolutely suck to make anyway moving on
I wanted to have a couple of small like
terrorists like areas around this part
of the rock as well just to make it a
little bit more symmetrical not
symmetrical in a sense that both sides
of the rock are completely symmetrical
but just
to make it look as you approach it from
the little like it's a little bit more
of a coherent rock and not like it's
divided into two sides which are
completely different I also don't want
to make like this side of it a little
bit heavier and a little bit taller
which you can only really tell if you
look at it from like the front
perspective but that's kind of because
this tower on this side on the left side
of the little is a little bit taller as
well so I didn't want to have like a
little bit more dense scenery and more
spread out and tall scenery around this
side to kind of mirror how the tower on
this side is a bit taller as well and
aside from that the general scenery
strategy of this area is pretty simple
and fun to follow just place many
barrels and related scenery items to add
some extra life to it and some extra
detail as well and truth be told I know
this is something that PewDiePie always
says but if you don't really know what
to do with an area you can always just
fill it with barrels and leave that
that's it's never really a bad idea to
add some extra small details around
places just as long as it's like not
your main focus I would say just as long
as it's something you kind of add until
you're done with the rest I I would say
it's best to sort of leave it as the
final sort of addition to an area and
yeah that's basically what I wanted to
do around here I also wanted to get into
some foliage which is actually quite
funny I think after the first video
already I got some comments telling me
that I should like try uses leap at the
least amount of footage I could just
because it's a steampunk thing and it's
pretty industrial and it should probably
reflect that in the foliage as well
which I definitely agree with I just
can't really help myself and still place
a little foliage around here not to
really make an overgrown look or make it
really cozy or natural and fancy in that
sort of sense but just I figured it
would look a little bit better to offset
the very gritty and dark sort of
atmosphere because even though steampunk
might be very pretty and industrial it's
not per se dystopian and I didn't want
to make this look a little bit more
child-friendly and more of a happy
future ride
in like some sort of alternate future
where we're still using steam machines
and yeah I basically wanted to do that
with the foliage as well just in general
though I do have to say I did want to
choose a specific pallets for the
foliage so I did go with the darker
colors in general and I did change the
palette up a little bit since the last
episode because I originally figured I
wouldn't really go with like the red
flowers and the purple bush but I think
they're actually quite good to add as
well just to get some extra color into
the foliage not to mention that much of
this scenery is very Brown very dark
grey ish and the foliage at least can
help to get some some bright colors and
some different colors in there as well
now I wanted to have another bridge over
here so the Q does like a little double
bridge thing of course I didn't want to
have a slightly different design for
this bridge but it's quite similar to
the other bridge just some slight
differences in how it's made and it's a
little more narrow since the other
bridge doesn't really just function as a
bridge I figured but also would kind of
be the entrance to the station and as
for the hill on the middle I have no
idea actually what I'm gonna do with
that I figured I would place a chimney
on it in the past but I don't think
that's a really good idea given that I
already have two weenies in this point
of this coaster which is already quite a
lot and I can already kind of sense the
station and two towers of the lift sail
kind of struggling for attention
especially if you kind of have them in
one shot they work really well on
separate shots but and both of them
together I figured having a chimney as
well which is also kind of tall and
draws a lot of attention wouldn't be
really great because then the entire
area with well be kind of unfocused and
just be a lot of sort of separate parts
that don't really fit together as well
and at the moment I feel it just fits
together nicely with the station and
while the tower is on the hill being
spaced out a bit and having that sort of
gap in between them which is both the
gap in a sense that it's lower and has
less scenery so I don't want to get too
much scenery in the rest of the area but
I still want to get some simple stuff
around the queue just because it's the
queue and I'm doing have some scenery
around it obviously for people to look
at
since the queue is part of a theme park
as well and you don't want to bore
people in the queue and yeah I'll
basically see what I'm gonna do with
that in the future I might actually
place a chimney around it but just make
it really small and well not so
attention-grabbing
chimney which is something that I've
already sort of tried but fill that a
couple of times so we'll see how that
goes in the future and for this little
ride I tip one to have just a little bit
of play between the exit and the
entrance path so I figured it would be
cool to have that little bridge go over
the entrance path and have a well pretty
standard sort of Rock of rings around
the flat ride with just a lot of simple
foliage and stuff like that I'm probably
not going to really theme this in any
sort of serious sense though I am
thinking about maybe putting a little
roof on top of that bridge I think that
would be kind of cute and at some point
in the future I'm probably gonna want to
add a little house to the flat ride for
the person who I completely forgot their
name to sit in anyway the person who
watches over the ride the right operator
there we go
it is realistically seen I tuna have
something for the blind operators
somewhere and the rest of it I am not
really sure what I'm gonna do with this
area now this here is basically more or
less the last part of the video and
swimming which I'm actually quite happy
with how it worked out in the end
basically we have these sort of entrance
yellow archway things which is fine and
dandy because wow it's something that
rollercoaster [ __ ] has always had I
guess but these are like really obvious
and big and really hard to work around
and I guess it works in a generic sort
of theming but right now I have this
golden metallic gates for the queue for
a steampunk theme which does not really
work well
and so I really wanted to try to get rid
of that thing but it's impossible to get
rid of it so I figured if you can't beat
him might as well join him and build
something around that thing and that was
basically my intention with this little
spire here which kind of failed at first
because it was a bit too big a bit too
fat I figured and this is a little bit
more lean so I figured it would work a
little bit well a little bit better with
the Victorian theming and yeah that kind
of helps to get rid of the top of the
yellow supports and the rest can pretty
much be handled by supports and a little
bit of like a small building in a sort
of pavilion kind of sense around this
little spire just to make the entrance
into a nice little theming thing while
at the same time getting rid of the
awkward yellow gate which completely
breaks the immersion I have no clue what
I'm gonna do with the other yellow gates
for the flat ride yet I do think I want
to do something with it just because
it's such an awkward thing but that's
probably something to just think about
in the future this is just something
which I figured it would work quite well
in this specific case and I definitely
think it's a really cool and fun idea to
just try and get rid of these yellow
gates and all sorts of different ways
and see how you can work around them
though it definitely kind of depends on
the theme it is in the sense I figured
it would work just to have like a little
Victorian pavilion around here to make
that a cute little entrance but I can
definitely see it being a lot harder in
some other themes to get rid of this
yellow gates in a sort of realistic and
good-looking way this might also be like
the little operator booth for whoever
would control the queue if it's really
necessary
so I'm actually quite happy with how
this works and you don't really notice
it in the time-lapse or you kind of saw
it for a couple of seconds there
probably I also really wanted to have
the little house over there because it's
a really important sight line for the
two towers as you sort of approach the
queue so you kind of have the small
house of the queue entrance in the
foreground if you stand there and in the
background behind the bridge which also
actually helps
to get that force perspective going you
can see the towers well it's not so much
force perspective it's just framing but
I'm just really happy with how that
sight line in general turnouts because
that's just one of the three main sight
lines from which I built the towers and
which I wanted to make sure that they
would work from that perspective
basically because they're more or less
made for her that perspective and the
rest is just a bit of really simple path
essentials I wanted to have some
lanterns but not use these same lanterns
around the entire park and in general
when it comes to path essentials like
lanterns benches and litter bins I like
to change them up a little bit which
obviously is a bit harder given that we
have pretty much none of those things at
the moment except for a couple of
streetlights but even the fake ones I
kind of prefer to mix them up a bit
instead of going with the same sort of
predictable ones all over the park
anyway that's it for the time lapse
point today but I do still have a real
time pots so I'm gonna give it over to
my past self here all right so here's
how things are shaping up at the moment
it is actually quite largely finished
already and a lot more than I expected
the main part of the ride is definitely
more or less done at this point maybe
except for a small things that I wanted
to wreak but I definitely want to keep
this overall area the way it is at the
moment though there is still some
scenery to be placed around here I'm not
entirely sure what I'm gonna do with it
I'd like a couple of experiments with
some chimneys and
still have to figure out exactly how I
want to get the shape perfectly right
but I'm probably gonna plant a chimney
right around here in this corner just to
have something interesting because this
is also like a pretty important sight
line over here since this is also the
entrance of the ride with that with that
little building just kind of getting rid
of the ugly yellow steel thing which we
have at the moment there will be things
to choose from in the future which are
really awesome but at the moment we
don't really have any other options but
just try to hide that as much as I can I
guess so I'm quite happy with how this
in general turned out but I would still
like to have something on these rocks to
kind of offset the scenery on this side
and I might also get into some stuff
with the brake run there were a couple
of comments in the last video that I'm
when it get like some machinery and
gears stuff like that around the breaker
on to make it look a bit more
interesting and also add some steampunky
and feel in there which I think I
definitely want to try I'm not going to
add a trench with wreck just because I
don't have any space for it which is
quite awkward I was figuring at some
point that I might make like a track go
underneath the station there is not
really enough space to realistically
make that happen so this coaster is not
going to have a transfer track which is
kind of a shame but I would actually
really like to do some other interesting
stuff with a break run and as for the
rest of the ride it's more or less going
to stay this way like I just want to
have some more interesting scenery and
flowers around here this is just a bit
of a placeholder at the moment and my
plan has always been and I might want to
get into that especially since the ride
is already finished - quite a good
degree to get some buildings around here
and make this like a string of facades
to kind of connect it to whatever the
rest of the park would be it's kind of
laid out as if it were like one small
Disney area that kind of thing and
that's also the idea where I want to add
like an area over here to be able to
connect it to whatever rest of this park
it would be part of because I won't add
anything else to this part or to this
coaster but it's more or less laid out
in a way that it could be parts of like
a different Park as one separate themed
area and that's the general idea I still
kind of want to finish this as well and
yeah that's basically all of my plans at
the moment which I don't know how many
episodes I can still pull out of this I
kind of predicted it would be 7 to 10
episodes and four episodes in and I'm
already done more than I actually
expected beforehand so I don't know it
might be a shorter series or I might get
interviewed like some really detailed
stuff alongside the buildings of this
little path here but I've got some other
projects that I kind of want to show as
well anyway I want to get back to work
so thank you guys for watching and I
hope to see you guys in the next video